Justin Bieber and Haley Baldwin are
happily married and on the hunt for a
home it's an amazing feeling for sure it
seems mr. and mrs. Bieber are looking to
keep each other company permanently we
have a good time together he's just
really sweet he's a good kid good a
source tells ET Justin and Haley have
checked out Demi Lovato's Los Angeles
home with a realtor quote they've been
renting for a while Justin and Haley
wants something that is gated and safe
with a lot of space a pool and they are
open to what area they live in this
would make Demi's nine point four
million dollar mansion the perfect space
for the lovebirds to settle down it's a
four-bedroom six bathroom private estate
with a pool and bar just minutes away
from the Sunset Strip
despite the property being the same
place demi was found before she was
hospitalized in July our source says the
couple is not concerned that the house
was at the center of a media storm after
Demi Lovato's apparent drug overdose
there
and Justin appears to be in good spirits
following a week of looking sombre after
news broke that his ex Selena Gomez
checked herself into a mental facility I
want to be wait free after a day of
house hunting here's Justin waving and
smiling with his 21 year old wife as
they left a midweek service at Hillsong
Church Wednesday night it's nice to see
the newlyweds all smiles as they set the
foundation for their future
[Music]
[Music]